she with David Brock author of the book
blinded by the right he talks about the
book and his former career as a
conservative journalist this is about an
hour hello and welcome to the newseum in
arlington virginia for this week's close
up at the newseum discussion hi I'm John
molesky of the close-up foundation in
just a moment you'll hear from high
school students and adults participating
in close-up program this week but first
I want to introduce you to our topic and
guests joining us is David Brock he is
the author of blinded by the rice the
conscience of an ex conservative in the
book he chronicles his role in the so
called vast right-wing conspiracy of the
Clinton years and along the way tells
many provocative tales about a variety
of influential political operatives his
other books include the real Anita Hill
and the seduction of Hillary Rodham he
has written for Esquire Rolling Stone
talk and done op-eds for the New York
Times in the Washington Post's David
welcome to the discussion thanks for
having me David in the first line in
your book in the prologue says and I
read it this is a terrible book it is
about lies told and reputations ruined
quite a way to come out of the starting
gate it begs the question why did you
decide to write it well I think there
are a couple reasons one is that the
work that I did as a conservative
activist / writer both on need a hill
and the early anti-clinton stories is
work that over time I came to regret and
realized in a lot of ways was mistaken
since those mistakes were made in a very
public way in ways that got a lot of
attention in the press and I think
affected people's views of public issues
I thought I owed it to the public to
write about my second thoughts about all
this and to put that on the record
second reason is related but I think
that the the the way that the media
treated the Clinton scandals over the
years as they were happening was I was
skewed in the sense that it tended to
virtually ignore the story that I tell
in this book which is the relentless
nature of the opposition to Bill Clinton
and I think that I
when historians look back and tried away
what really happened here to have all
that on the record to the short way of
phrasing that is to have the right wing
conspiracy revealed exposed and
documented by somebody who's actually in
it nobody else could do that because
nobody's actually been in it and left as
I have you just now when you you
described yourself back then as a
conservative activist / writer yeah but
at the time you thought of yourself as a
journalist I did I mean I thought of
myself as I was trying to combine two
roles basically I was trying to combine
the journalistic role of journalistic
hat with that of a conservative
political activists and ultimately that
didn't really work out so well as I
documented the book because the the bias
that was in my head the conservative
point of view I think was ultimately
disabling in terms of trying to
ascertain the truth of things and so
everything was tainted everything was
colored everything was filtered through
an ideological prism the Bernie
Goldbergs written a very successful book
about media bias where he charges right
wing or I me a good liberal media bias
not a new charge you use the phrase in
your book a number of times liberal
media but the also your tail describes
something quite different than a liberal
media right what is your analysis of
media bias well I think that um uh you
know this is something that the right
has long contended that there's a
liberal media bias and it's something
that I mentioned in the book because
it's part of how I was schooled my first
job out of college was at a magazine
published by The Washington Times and
and one of the goals one of the explicit
things that was said was we were
combating the so-called liberal slant in
the media I think it's changed over time
I think that if that was right twenty
years ago I certainly don't think in the
last ten years you really can say that
because they think that there's so many
other media voices now there's so much
alternative media you've got the Fox
News Network you've got a mazing
conservative presence and talk radio so
I think you've got now so many voices
that you've got you've got a good mix
and a good balance and actually I would
say that in terms of sort of sort of the
cable chat world and the experiences
I've had promoting this book versus
promoting
might need a whole book ten years ago
that you know there's there's almost a
conservative dominance in a lot of much
more of a market for the Anita Hill book
then for this book yeah well not so much
more market but it was a lot easier a
lot easier to sell because you know you
could do 400 conservative talk radio
shows I said to the publicist for this
book well we'll just do the liberal
shows and they said well actually you
know you'll be lucky if there's one in
every market so I certainly don't think
the Conservatives in terms of the media
or any more underrepresented at all
mm-hmm the another thing that you say in
the book is you fought on the wrong side
of an ideological and cultural war that
divided our country and poisoned our
politics why were you on the wrong side
well I mean I ultimately came to the
view that it was the wrong side I I
started and really cut my teeth in the
Bork nomination which was a major issue
in the conservative movement in a way I
think affected a lot of their strategy
and tactics in the sense that they felt
that bork had been unfairly maligned and
that gave them justification then to do
everything they were going to do it kind
of as payback then Soviet Union fell and
I think that people like Newt Gingrich
realized that conservatism only thrives
when it has an enemy and so that enemy
became various domestic groups that in
some ways were different and I think
that's where with Bork and then with
Soviet Union falling you had culture war
that ultimately manifested itself most
vividly in the nineteen ninety two
Republican convention the reason I was
on the wrong side of that is because
even when I was defending work even when
I was celebrating Newt Gingrich on
social issues I always was a was
basically a liberal I came to Washington
and and what happened was a process of
subordinating my own views and values to
those that I could see were a path to
being accepted and succeeding in the
conservative movement and so I sold
myself out and your first reaction to an
ad Hills testimony is that you believed
her is that correct that's right yeah
these are sort of flashes of my own
conscience that come out in the book
here and there but again that that
ultimately I don't listen to and there's
a scene in the book where I was at the
Washington Times of the time and they're
about 10-12 colleagues in my office
watching a Nita he'll testify on a
Friday morning and I was the only one in
the room after her testimony was
completed who said that she seemed
credible and that it was it seemed
unbelievable almost impossible that
someone would put themselves on national
television was such an elaborate story
if there wasn't truth in it that's what
I felt Friday morning by Sunday
afternoon watching the way the
Conservatives rallied around Clarence
Thomas and seeing all the issues that
were at stake in the hearing I was
influenced by basically everybody around
me and came out of the hearing feeling
that he was wrongly accused and that's
the first article that I wrote that got
me a lot of attention in the
conservative movement one way to
interpret that story and then the larger
story is that what you had an amazing
capacity to convince yourself or lie to
yourself about what you wanted to
believe that's right and then the
ultimate outcome of that is that you
could lie to a larger audience that's
right is so the credibility question
looms large why can we believe now that
you've got it straight okay well um I
mean there are a couple reasons I think
the most obvious one to me is that this
book is filled with names and dates and
places my recollections are quite
specific and the book has been out now
for about two months and with a few
exceptions the characters in this book
have not come forward to dispute
anything and I take the reader in to the
room where plans are being hatched where
checks are being written I name the name
seriously these things didn't happen I
think we'd know about the Conservatives
generally or not people who are who are
shy about about coming out and saying
you know this isn't true right you say
the Solicitor General titles and lied
under oath and that's why not refute
that well he he sort of has a I mean
this issue came up in in his testimony
before the Senate when he was nominated
as Solicitor General and he sort of
bobbed and weaved around this question
of what exactly his role was in the
Arkansas project but I know what it was
I was there just at the time he was and
he was quite involved with the project
he's tried to downplay that during his
Senate confirmation I think because not
because anything illegal happened but I
think that because it was and will
probably talk about this some more but
this Arkansas project was was nothing
more than a well-funded character
assassination plan against the Clintons
it was the epitome of the politics of
personal destruction quote-unquote and
Ted Olson helped engineer that he also
helped when it was when it was sort of
coming apart within the magazine because
of allegations that money was being
misspent he engineered the cover-up of
that and so I think those were
legitimate issues for him to be asked
about in the Senate and I think he
misled the Senate when he testified the
way he did was the Arkansas project in
your mind the the epicenter of the
so-called vast right-wing conspiracy
it's a part of it I think they're
basically two prongs one is the Arkansas
project which is funded was funded by
richard melon Scaife who is one of the
founding fathers of the modern
conservative movement but is by no means
a household name he decided to spend
about 2.2 million dollars just at the
American Spectator just in this project
meantime there are tens of millions of
dollars washing through every other
conservative organization in town to get
the Clintons this was not to go back to
your question about conservatism and
journalism this wasn't journalism this
was a political operation so that was
part of it I think the other part which
i also played a role sort of
unintentionally in is the Paul Jones
sexual harassment suit that was filed
against Bill Clinton and when you look
back and construct how you got from from
Paul Jones to impeachment the Jones case
became the vehicle for the conspiracy it
wasn't terribly vas
there were a few people involved a lot
of financial backing very single-minded
and there is a section in the book where
I described in 1997 which is six months
before anybody hears the name Monica
Lewinsky that one of Jones's lead
lawyers tells me not only does he not
believe his client but basically
explains to me the strategy that becomes
the perjury trap that they've spent four
years on a fishing expedition backed by
tens of thousands of dollars from
conservative movement to dig up every
rumor they can about Bill Clinton and
that they are consciously maneuvering to
get him into a deposition format where
at a minimum they can then leak and
humiliate the President I don't think
they actually imagined she'd get to
impeachment but that this was a plan and
I think that plan is the conspiracy and
by conspiracy you know it yeah that's a
business overstated but conspiracy
suggests the organization how organized
it was organized I mean all that
conspiracy means is a wrongful scheme
and I think if people look at this book
and not only this book there been a
couple other books written on the
subject Jeff Toobin book I vast
conspiracy came to it I think from what
anyone would consider a neutral point of
view and also use the word conspiracy
basically what you're talking about is
his organization and money and you're
talking about what I think anybody would
conclude was an abuse of the legal
process for partisan political reasons
and I think that that's what's wrong
phul about this game you mentioned the
92 convention in Houston and a critical
piece about you that maybe you've read
by Chris Hitchens yeah one or two page
review and he the question he raises his
wait a second did it take the Houston
Convention for you to realize that there
was an anti-gay movement within the
Republican Party or a religious right
movement surrender because you sort of
point to that as a turning point in your
thinking about your own life and where
you were and what you were doing right
well I think what I say about 92 is that
becomes a point where I can't deny to
myself what's going on and you talked a
little bit before which I agree with is
is a one thing we're talking about in
terms of being blinded is not
so much blinded by the right but blinded
by myself and my own capacity for
self-deception so it's not that in the
mid 80s in late 80s I wasn't aware that
there was an anti-gay strain in the
Republican Party and in fact I write
about it I write about Jerry Falwell's
backing for Ronald Reagan it's that in
92 on national television watching
things unfold as they did that became a
point where I consciously knew that I
had allied myself with the wrong side
and so the rationalization and the
denial of that was no longer possible
and yet I still marched it how many
years later later you in continues we
finally made the break-up well it
depends on how you look at it but at
least for another three or four years
yeah was it in the publishing of the
Hillary Clinton book that was that the
beginning of the end it was it was in
the process of writing that book that I
came to question a lot of the
fundamentals and that I came to doubt a
lot of what the conservatives were
saying about the Clintons from a lot of
first-hand experience I had in Arkansas
doing a lot of reporting for that book
trying really trying to make the worst
case I could against Hillary Clinton and
finding that factually it could not be
done and that really shook my
foundations a lot and so in the process
which took two years of churning is sort
of my first step out of the conservative
movie you know it sounds almost in a
perverse way you became more of a
journalist's that you became more and
more concerned about the credibility of
your work there for you got more
involved in fact checking and not
extrapolating from the stories you had
in making them more than they were oh
yeah I definitely think that's the case
I think that part of the part of that
struggle was within myself to be able to
see things in a gray area and most good
journalists are critical and skeptical
and I had a very I think black and white
mindset and seeing that the truth of
Hillary Clinton who after all is a human
being and is not perfect but also can't
be evil trying to portray that as a real
biographer would which I think I largely
succeeded doing
was was a big step i think you continue
to be out of step with the times yeah
well that's definitely is now the
journalism has turned to this
black-and-white sort of crossfire type
paradigm and when you're trying to move
into a more gray area that's definitely
true I was actually thinking about that
yesterday that some of the very early
stuff I was doing with Anita Hill and
Bill Clinton ten years later that's sort
of how a lot of our politics is
discussed now on shows like hardball
where you know really people are not
only shouting their point of view but
they're definitely there isn't a lot of
room for ambiguity okay let's go to our
three audiences questions yes sir your
first hi my name is Keenan Brown and I'm
from Washington DC mr. Brock out of all
the books that you have written so far
do you have a favorite one and why well
i think that uh you know in this book I
retract my first book the real anita
hill so that can't be on the favorite
list the Hillary Clinton book is still
important to me personally because of
what I just described because I think
had I not undertaken that topic and work
my way through that the way I did the
transition that I made which has been so
so good for me wouldn't have happened
and I think that this book is probably
the one that will stand the test of time
though better than bent better than
either one of them and so if I have to
pick a favorite i'll pick this one yes
sir hello mr. Brock my name is Clinton
rifle and I live in Washington DC what
question you was what made you come up
with the truth with his thumbs
spiritually or or F Nicola what um yeah
I think that I mean it's been a long
process thing that I did that I regret
the most was one point after I wrote my
book on Anita Hill and Clarence Thomas
almost two years later I was asked to
review a book on the same topic that had
some damaging information in it about
Thomas and took hillside
it's a long story that I tell him the
book but to make a long story short
because I had defended Thomas so
vociferously I had earned a certain
level of trust from people around him as
a result of publishing my book and so I
had better access to what they really
felt and really believed I found out
that some of this damaging information
about Thomas in this other book which
was called strange justice was true
instead of writing the truth then this
is late nineteen ninety-four I continue
to cover that up and attack Anita Hill
and attack the writers of that book and
that's when I really hit rock bottom and
I knew that I had written something that
wasn't true consciously which is the
first and last time I ever did that that
I was a fraud in in the claims that I
was making and so I think that after
hitting rock bottom I did have a crisis
of conscience and I did resolve to not
repeat those mistakes again and so since
then I've been on a path of of
struggling to do to do the right thing
and so yeah I think it involved ethics
much more than it did politics although
ultimately there's a political and
ideological transformation involved in
what I've gone through as well which is
sort of finding my own values and acting
on them and the reporters who wrote
strange justice or a couple of Wall
Street Journal reporters that's
legitimate sources and oh absolutely
call it was not yeah right you know I
know I've asked the credibility question
before you just ask again how he came to
this sort of awakening right but let me
come at it one more time in a what is
the most compelling case you could make
two people that would say you know
believe me now in a way that you
couldn't have before cuz by your own
admission you couldn't be believed
before right and the people you describe
your I mean quite frankly it's a world
of scoundrels where the truth is barely
a consideration Wright it's really what
truth what manufacturers truth will
further an agenda right so if you're
coming to this from the outside without
a strong bias that suggests i want to
believe this person over this person
sure how does a person who is truly
coming in
trying to discern right the closest
thing to the truth sort through it okay
yeah well as I said before one is the
silence is deafening from the people
criticized okay let's put that aside
let's talk about why at this book you've
read it it's not terribly self-serving
there I think I'm harder on myself than
I am on anybody else in the book a lot
of things I write about in terms of
myself for quite unattractive I can't
imagine what any motivation would be to
not write the truth about that so once I
made a commitment to to come and clean
you know I just don't I just don't see
what the in terms of you put yourself in
my shoes what's the what's the upside to
well I guess Celebi no to sell a book to
create a best-seller that would be even
at the expense of your own I mean
because the thing is here's to patrick
ago at the you were doing at the expense
of your own life I mean your personal
strongly held beliefs whether it be
about pro-life for tolerance toward gay
people or whatever the the radical cause
might be you were certainly putting that
at jeopardy for yourself and for others
yeah but that when I was doing that I
think that what I was doing was taking
an easy path it was easy to do what I
did before to put my head in the sand to
succeed in the way I did this hasn't
been the easy path i think the easy
thing to have done you take your lumps
with this path yes i think when the easy
thing to have done would have been you
know perhaps I broke with the
conservative movement fine move on you
know continue doing what I was doing
which was in 97 98 writing for a lot of
the magazines you mentioned and having a
successful freelance journalistic career
but I just I just felt like I couldn't
do that I couldn't move on without
disclosing all these things that had
happened and the reason I made that
decision was that this stuff was really
weighing on me and there are couple
scenes in the book where at what you
would consider inappropriate moments the
things from the
that I knew I was just spilling out
people in private settings and I knew
this just had to be written down for
English people in addition to success
obviously another thing you were seeking
is acceptance uh-huh and what's your
take on where you are right now in life
do you still need that acceptance now
just from a different group of people or
have you gotten beyond that I think I
have gotten very much beyond that and
that's one of the things I mean in terms
of my emotional attraction to the
conservative movement and to being in
what was almost kind of like a cult
which has its own system of rewards and
incentives and disincentives I really
took to that and I think that a big part
of that was needing to feel embraced and
accepted I've been on my own for a while
now I got fired from the american
spectator in 1997 and I don't work for
anybody nobody's paying me to write what
I'm writing except you know a publishing
house not anybody with any political
interest and so you know I'm sort of out
there on my own and standing on my own
two feet and that feels good and you
know it's not to say that I'm not aware
that there are people on the left to
have written positively about this book
and have appreciated that this book but
when i get those compliments they just
don't feel the way they used to feel
from the conservatives um I can I have
CJ about 8am as much now yeah i feel
like i don't need it as much and i have
a have a certain distance from it and
it's great but you know I've I'm also
aware that there are people who for
whatever reason have their political
interests are gonna like you for saying
what you're saying now versus then and I
can see that for what it is too um so
you know there must you must have had
some allies within the movement that
were similarly minded to you who also
maybe were compromising a lot of their
strongly held beliefs to move forward
where are they oh I mean I there are
there other allies that where why
haven't they abandoned the movement and
come clean well I think because it
doesn't but we well we just discussed it
doesn't necessarily do much for you to
do that I mean I'm gonna be 40 years old
in July it's not easy to not only in in
in the kind of you know crossfire
journalism network
about where you brand yourself as
conservative so therefore you know
you're working on one side and and
that's how you market yourself but in
politics generally you don't see people
i mean jim jeffords did it but that's
that's an odd case you don't see people
who spend 10 15 20 years working for
once I'd make a make a smooth transition
a lot of plenty where else that's right
and so I think it's just it's just not
plausible but I think you're right and
one of the things that I do write in
this book is that I don't think i was
such an exception particularly among my
own age group I think that sure there
are people 20 years older than than I am
who were more steeped in the ideology of
it and probably did have stronger
beliefs but I think a lot of people who
who I knew who were in my age group and
even those who are a little younger came
to it at a time when it was great stick
and it worked well and the anti-clinton
thing was amazingly lucrative for a lot
of people and I think people just you
know they're just not going to walk away
from that hi oh hi my name is amber I'm
also from DC um the way you said that
she lied to the public I was wondering
if um if you intended to mislead people
from the beginning or was it that later
on you kind of figured or found out that
you have been spreading lies right
that's a good question no when I wrote
the first book I believed that what I
was writing was true when I wrote those
early anti-clinton stories i also
believe them to be true it was only
later through a combination of things
one is finding out more information
later one is being able to I think what
we talked about assess the credibility
of sources as I got older as I did more
work that I could see what the flaws
were in a lot of the work so there
really is only the one time that I
discussed in terms of that book review
of strange justice where that was a
conscious act of this
option all the other stuff I was
well-intentioned and sincere and writing
it at the time I was writing it it was
only later that I was able to see get
beyond the bias get beyond the ideology
and look at how those things were
constructed to see what the flaws were
in them and that took some time but
ultimately that's a big part of what
this book is explaining the process of
how that could happen Thanks hi my name
is Lynn Peterson and I'm from Portland
Oregon you mentioned having taken your
lumps and I wonder if you have been
subject to personal attacks from the
right wing since you left the right wing
and what you expect your relationship
how you expect to what kind of career
you expect to develop now that you have
you know change parties good question
well on the first question yes I mean
this and and this process of change that
we're talking about it didn't happen
overnight in 1997 I wrote an article in
Esquire where I broke ranks with the
conservative movement that was called
the confessions of a right-wing hit man
in 1998 during the impeachment I
apologize to President Clinton for some
of the things that had gone on with the
Paul Jones case that I was involved in
and at each step of the way there have
been a lot of ad hominem attacks by the
conservatives and a you know character
assassination etc but what hasn't really
happened is a i think a reason challenge
on the substance of what i'm saying
about them i think they're probably in
denial about their own history so that's
what I would say about the Conservatives
as far as my future career you know I
expect that I will write another book
I'm working on defining a subject at the
moment and I you know I am still
interested in writing and I'm still
interested in politics I think that what
I was advocating before was the wrong
thing but I don't think that I had that
I had absolutely no talent and so i
think i'll continue to to do along the
lines of what I've done here which is to
write about subjects that interest me
are you considering in a give a sling
way a sense of what you're considering a
subject matter well I think I mean I
think I'll stay you know in in on a
political subject and I'll probably
write something thats related to what's
going on now with the Bush
administration I don't know exactly know
how it'll be structured I'm also
interested in in something that I touch
on in this book but don't develop all
that much which was the relationship
between the mainstream media and the
conservative movement and how it would
have been impossible for the
conservative movement to achieve what it
did without it without some success in
affecting how the mainstream media
viewed particularly the Clintons and I
think that's an interesting thread as
well hi hi my name is Dante Furioso i'm
also a high school student from
Washington DC and I was curious if
seeing is how now you you say you've
gotten beyond the bias that you you know
we're experiencing for so long and so
heavily before I was curious if you see
yourself at a point where your views
could continue to change and if you know
possibly you might move more you know it
towards the left or attach yourself once
again to a certain group even though now
you say you are more you know
independent I just care about the
right-wing hitman two left-wing hitman
is it possible well I think that I mean
one of the things i found out in the
experiences that I've had is you know
the ability to change your mind about
things is it can be a really good thing
and so you know as terms of various
issues what I expect that I'd continue
to
you know develop in terms of ideological
commitments I suppose I will I right at
the end of the book that even though I
registered as an independent in two
thousand that I voted for al gore and
that's a vote that I'm still proud of
and I think for the foreseeable future
the on a national level anyway I
wouldn't see myself were supporting the
Republican Party and I don't expect
that'll change i mean i think one thing
too about ideological conversions
there's a there's a whole history of
people have done this and most of them
have written books about it and i think
when you make a change in the middle of
life after learning a lot you know tend
to stick with that change i think so i
think you only do this once even though
i think you refine your views as you go
and i expect to do that i don't expect
to find myself back on the right at any
time as you want to continue in an
advocacy mode or would you like to be a
straightforward journalist well uh no I
think that um I mean what I was saying
the last questioner is that I think that
uh I do have the mindset of an advocate
and so I think that even though I was
advocating things that I no longer
believed to be true I think that will
always be a component in my writing I
don't expect to go get a job at a
newspaper and write things perfectly
down the middle I just don't expect that
yeah hi my name is Anthony Thompson i'm
also a washington DC high school student
and i was wondering what made you begin
your deceptive career early on where you
paid or bribed or was this yeah yeah um
no I I guess you know my first
experiences and what led me to become a
conservative happened in in college I
went to Berkeley which has very
liberal reputation and I think that as
part of kind of youthful rebellion I was
in some ways reacting against the
prevailing liberalism at Berkeley and so
found some satisfaction in identifying
myself with a conservative movement and
when I came out of Berkeley I was
exclusively looking for jobs on
conservative publications and so it
wasn't it was it was a it was a youthful
ideological zeal at first I really
didn't have anything to do with making
money that came later it wasn't really
apparent to me at that time that that
was even a great career path it was just
I had felt that I wanted to advance the
conservative cause and I had always even
back in high school been interested in
writing and so I tried to combine the
two and I think that was that was that
was how things started and the the ideal
of of the career being anything that
would get me no nor be lucrative much
less than any of the deception that all
came later but there was you know as you
say I mean there there was there were
specific cases where and I write about
this in the book and I think again this
is it's pretty unusual where people
within the conservative movement
essentially commissioned articles and
the first article that what case of me
on the map it's you not even through the
meds right we haven't talked all that
much about this the underworld of the
anti-clinton conspiracy but in one case
a one of the man named Peter Smith who
was a financier of of Newt Gingrich's go
pack wrote a five-thousand-dollar check
to have me go down to Arkansas and
and do some of the early anti-clinton
research that ultimately became part of
the Arkansas project at the American
Spectator ran but you had
self-interested political parties and
the same as is true of how do you need a
hill story started with a check to the
spectator from someone who is on the
board of a pro Clarence Thomas
organization so you know you can't
really call that journalism I think and
by any definition used here at the
newseum right yes jay harbor from
claremont california mr. Brooks I was
very impressed with your comment your
description about the ability of persons
the capacity of persons for
self-deception I was wondering if you'd
be willing to comment about how you've
observed that capacity in those around
you and also what advice would you give
for those who work in the religious and
social realms in trying to deal with
this personality flaw and social ill
have you observed any of it today go
ahead let they take the gloves off well
no I think obviously I wasn't the only
one who was afflicted with this this
ability to deceive oneself because
you'll see if you read the book that
there's an interesting phenomenon which
is that many of the people who made the
most outlandish accusations against the
Clintons wore themselves doing exactly
what they were accusing the Clintons of
doing and people ask me how could this
possibly be I mean let's take Newt
Gingrich who is having an extramarital
affair during this period where he said
you know I'm going to say the word
Monica in every speech until you know
Bill Clinton's resigns or is impeached
you know what's the thought process of
somebody who is so vulnerable themselves
on these same issues I don't know it's a
time about mr. gingrich's yeah
discretion in fact Russians the earliest
that I can remember is that after the
republicans took control congress in
1994 i was hearing in social settings in
early 95 concern of people around
gingrich that he would be subjected to a
different kind of scrutiny now that he
was speaker and that he was vulnerable
on things like this and and of course
it's not just gingrich i mean i think
that there's there was endemic hypocrisy
in the conservative movement and part of
that is part of that self-deception i I
guess it is I guess it's it's a view
that that the end justifies the means
and and that what they're doing is is
okay because because their goals are the
right goals and even though they're
doing the same thing Clinton's doing
Clinton's goals or the wrong goals so he
can be taken down and destroyed for
those things I suppose that's part of it
well I mean that's just when in
following up on your question that's an
interesting concept and that there's an
ethical standard that is you can lie or
you can do something unethical for a
greater good that's in other words you
can lie to terrorists to save lives of
hostages that would be one example are
you suggesting that these people weren't
lying that's the way they were lying
that they thought that ultimately they
were their cause was righteous and so
their lie was acceptable in this larger
war I think so because I think that the
ideology was almost like a religion for
many people and I think that that
permitted people to take a lot of
liberties with the truth on things that
they saw as not as important as the goal
of attaining political power for their
own partisan ends yeah sir was part of
your question sort of how does somebody
guard against self-deception you just
you could just not I know you don't have
a microphone over there now but was that
part of your question yeah you care to
address that part I mean you've been
this your life story that you tell would
certainly make you expert in that regard
yeah sure what advice as you've asked
for could you give and how do you check
yourself when you're trying to look at
your own political views well I think a
lot of it just comes from
a certain kind of self-awareness that I
didn't have and I was not a terribly
[ __ ] reflective person I as you'll see
when particularly in the early years I
never really second-guessed anything I
did I just charged ahead with a mission
and the mission was you know defeating
the left and so I left out of bed in the
morning and and went to it and so this
period that I've been through in the
last four or five years has been a
period of you know perhaps too much
self-reflection it feels like at this
point but I think it was necessary and I
think you know obviously thinking about
the moral consequences of your actions
is really the key and for whatever
reason I think there are a lot of people
who may be attracted to politics who
don't have that capacity and I'm
certainly not the only one it was
blinded mmm so it's not necessarily
assuming you're wrong no extreme it's
assuming that maybe you're not right I
think that's a great way of putting at
you hi oh yeah i'm i'm curious on
because you've been involved on all
sides of the political political
spectrum i'm curious on your take being
that choices are directly related to
freedom and seems the more choices we
have the more freedom we have I'm
curious as to whether you believe the
two-party system which exists here in
the country actually limits the
potentials of our democracy it's a good
question i think that one thing that
that that has been limiting about it i
think is that you know it's permitted
there to be excesses on both sides and
one thing i've been criticized in this
book for is focusing just on you know
excesses of the conservatives i think
that the excess of the Conservatives
have been in the period that i write
about unprecedented but i do think that
that what's happened in general is that
there's been much less discussion of the
substance of politics and the issues of
politics and too much on a personality
and personal attack and i think it's
possible that because because you
haven't had
a healthier debate you haven't had
people stand up even within the parties
to take different points of view and
that both are so so much down one line
or another that that things are
developed in a way that there doesn't
seem to people to be a lot of choice
between the two is it safe to assume
that that's where you're coming from
with that question that you don't think
there's much choice between the two
major parties yeah I feel like as
perhaps citizens of a country we may
benefit from having more choices you
know you know you know I think it's hard
to argue with that but I will say what
are the issues though at stake in other
words this isn't all just about
destruction for destructions sake of
individuals no I was gonna say I mean I
think that it's wrong to say that the
part i mean i think that that that
unfortunately partly because of what's
happened to the debate and partly
because of the way that the debate takes
place with so much of it in in crossfire
formats that that what has gotten lost
is that there are fundamental
distinctions between it well let's take
the case of the boiler yeah let's take
the case of Bill Clinton and those eight
years Bill Clinton led the charge on
welfare reform he out Republican the
Republicans in certain issues so part of
you know if you're looking at this from
a purely public policy standpoint you
might say hey you're getting some of the
things you want what's your problem with
this guy right so what are the issues
that weren't being furthered under the
Clinton years or bi or the opposite of
that what was he promoting that people
were so outraged about well that's a
great question it's a little complicated
I think that um you would think that
because Clinton successfully moderated
triangulated co-opted certain Republican
issues that that would mean there'd be
less Republican opposition but actually
it worked the opposite way the better
Clinton did the more successful Clinton
was the more it became apparent that he
was going to survive and had
awesome political skills the more
desperate the Republicans became and so
I think that by robbing them of certain
issues and leaving them basically with
social issues that were not terribly
popular in the country and still or not
they left them with a very limited
agenda and so I think that's why they
began to focus on a lot of the scandal
as a means of getting the Clintons and
that there was this frantic search for a
silver bullet on something that would be
proven unethical and so the the issues
really weren't that debated all that
much and I think that on as many things
for powers sake right that it's who gets
credit not what gets done absolutely
right and I think that that that you're
right that the on in ideological terms
what were the conservative Jackson of
the Clintons I think a lot of it had to
do with what the Clintons symbolized not
so much what the Clintons did or didn't
do and if you look back at 1992 you see
that in the minds of the right the
Clintons are the first of their
generation to come into power in the
mind of the right that generation comes
out of the 1960s Hillary Clinton has her
own career so and then those early
issues gennifer flowers smoking pot
those are sort of cultural issues that
the right is trying to raise against
Bill Clinton and so I think the culture
war that we talked about earlier i think
the Clintons get ground up in the gears
of that culture war and that they
symbolize certain things even though I
think in a lot of ways wrongly they
certainly weren't cultural radicals but
that was with way the conservative saw
it and they can say they saw that as a i
think a unique threat in the sense that
they resisted all these social changes
since the 1960's and here they were
represented in this change now in in the
sense that we've had the 911 attacks and
now they're suddenly the sleeping giant
that had the luxury of debating
president's public or private lives now
suddenly has a foe and an imminent
threat does that change the politics
here because part of what you're
describing sounds to me like a politics
of complacency
we had the luxury of being
self-indulgent and getting into
moralizing back and forth who's more
righteous than home and but now we have
something else going on it do you think
this changes you know these people will
this change the players I don't think so
I mean I think it changes that the tenor
has changed for the moment for a couple
reasons one is the conservative tack
machine is not really geared up for
battle right now because they're in
power there's no reason to be and so I
think that once you move toward the next
presidential election cycle and once
there is a if there is a strong and
credible threat to to Bush you'll see
some of the same tactics I mean I think
it's a mistake and people make a mistake
to view what happened in the 90s as
being primarily about Clinton I think
that Clinton was targeted because he was
there and he was in their way and that's
as simple as that and that any Democrat
in the White would have been subject to
similar strategies yes and as soon as
somebody else gets in their way whether
it's tom daschle or somebody else and
we've already seen in the case of
Dashiell we've seen dashiell compared to
saddam hussein in republican issue
attack ads that have been run so the
tactics and the techniques are the same
I think that you're seeing them only in
use right now at the margins because the
war on terrorism is there similar
vitriolic rhetoric on the on the left no
I think there is a distinction and I
think that as I said you can point to
certain excesses on both sides but there
is nothing like the hate that emanates
from the conservative movement on the
other side that animates so much of
their politics I think there is nothing
like the organization on the liberal
side in terms of discipline you see a
very diffuse you really can't even use
the word liberal movement you see a very
diffuse coalition of interest
on the right you see very much a
top-down organization and you see that
they are very disciplined and they are
always on message so i think they fight
in very different ways and frankly I
mean I think the history of the use of
the political smear I think if you look
back even you know even back before this
the time period i'm talking about in
this book i think it comes out of the
republican party I do going back to
McCarthyism and this is really i mean in
some ways you can look at the 90s as a
second wave of McCarthyism yes ma'am hi
hi I'm Phyllis edgert San Francisco
challenge like you have matured and come
to terms with who you are and what what
you really believe in why thank you oh
I'm tried that must feel really good I'm
happy for you but all the people that
you have maligned what have you heard
from them and who is suing you okay
let's see well I haven't heard I have
written to Anita Hill twice apologizing
personally this book is a public apology
in a pretty major way but back in even
before I was thinking of writing a book
about this in early nineteen
ninety-eight I wrote I wrote a personal
note to Anita Hill and then last summer
when I finished the book I also book was
excerpted and talk magazine and I sent
her that excerpt and and wrote a
personal note to her as I mentioned
earlier she has not known as I mentioned
earlier I did during the height of the
impeachment try to make amends for some
of what I had done in terms of Clinton
and I was so much against the
impeachment I felt I needed to say
something about that and did write an
open letter to clinton then he did
publicly accept that apology at that
time so you know I can understand that
they'll still be some hard feelings and
and I would have him too because certain
you know certain kind of damage can't be
undone
because what I'm what I'm writing now is
really not in the heat of the moment
anymore and some of this damage was done
in the heat of the moment but I do think
there's a there's a I do think that
there's an appreciation particularly
among liberals for the idea of
redemption and so I hope that it will go
down pretty well second part of the
question in any litigation are you plan
on uh yeah okay no no actually no there
never has been and then there isn't in
this book certainly yes ma'am hi hi my
name is Amanda Proctor for Washington DC
and in dealing with politics and
reporters most stories I felt with lies
and exaggerations do you feel that it
makes you a better writer to be able to
tell the truth even though society and
the people crave entertainment over
every dance but are you assuming that
most of the things you read are filled
with lies or half-truths that's what
I've been told how do you know that
wasn't a lie oh it's all that no I think
I think it's a good practice to read
everything with questions take
everything with a grain of salt and I
think that particularly the idea that so
much of politics is now discussed in a
format that does strike a lot of people
as entertainment and with an
entertainment become comes over
statement and sometimes embellishment
than an overly dramatic kinds of
presentations so no I mean I I certainly
wouldn't say that I mean I think that I
have become a more balanced and reliable
person but I wouldn't hold myself up as
as better than anybody else in terms of
my journalism certainly there's a lot of
great journalism that's still practiced
today and so you know I wouldn't say
that at all man we have time for a very
quick final question Doris to hill from
Orleans Massachusetts Cape Cod I'm
listening to you in thinking this is
like a religious conversion that you had
can I ask personally was there something
and that triggered it I mean one event
maybe because what I'm hearing is you
did a lot of notetaking and fact-finding
on the Arkansas project do you deny the
things that you found there that you
investigated yeah I'm sorry to do this
to you okay thoughtful question that we
have about 20 seconds for you to respond
to well yes I mean I think that them as
I was saying earlier the credibility of
the people who told me things when I was
working on that Arkansas project i think
is pretty low and so i think that most
of what came out of that and these
things were spread all over the country
it wasn't just you know the arkansas
project the American Spectator the Vince
Foster rumors and drug dealing all these
things about the Clintons that were just
smears all the things they think we're
wrong and the conversion moment i think
if i have to point to one thing it was
this this issue of consciously telling
an untruth and print knowing this
damaging information about Clarence
Thomas covering it up seeing what I was
capable of seeing where the ideology had
led me and really hitting rock bottom
was the one one moment although they're
a series of other moments and there's
not one aha moment I think when I all of
a sudden see the light but you know it
does it is both a political and immoral
conversion I think the book is blinded
by the rice the author is David Brock
it's a good read you can judge for
yourself David thanks very much for
joining us thank you I thank you for
your questions and comments next week
we'll be back here in the newseum and
our discussion will be how press
coverage has evolved from the events of
911 to today's questions about
intelligence failures our guests will be
cox newspapers White House correspondent
Bob Dean's along with syndicated radio
talk show host Laura Ingraham until then
for all of us at the Freedom Forum
newseum and close up foundation I'm John
molesky thanks for watching